faut que ça a quand même pas mal
augmenté que soit genre fruits et
légumes la viande deux jeunes enfants en
fait le ça nous coûte en 300 dollars par
semaine
on poursuit là-dessus avec Maurice Doyon
professeur au département d'économie
agroalimentaire et des sciences de la
consommation de l'Université Laval
bonsoir Monsieur doyen
bonsoir merci d'être des nôtres pour
nous aider y voir un peu plus clair et
juste avant d'entreprendre notre
discussion un tableau pour qu'il nous
montre un peu le portrait de cette de
cette industrie finalement et des choix
de consommation que font les Canadiens
ou les Canadiens font-ils leur épicerie
voyez ici comment peu de joueurs
accapare une grosse partie du marché de
l'eau Blaze métro Costco sur base
Walmart et les autres mais c'est donc
c'est ces indépendants qui ont de la
difficulté à se tailler une place dans
le panorama canadien alors aidez-moi à
comprendre dans un premier temps
l'inflation alimentaire qui reste à 9%
alors que l'influenceur au sens général
est plutôt dans une tendance baissière
comment vous l'expliquer
en fait il faut regarder qu'est-ce que
constitue le coût de l'alimentation donc
bien entendu
les frais de transport sont un élément
les coûts d'énergie sont des éléments
importants et le travail donc ce sont
des éléments clés associés au coût de
l'énergie il y a les coûts des intrants
par exemple les engrais chimiques que
les agriculteurs utilisent et dans le
fond tous ces éléments tels que le coût
du financement règle générale les
agriculteurs ont aussi des un niveau
d'endettement relativement élevé donc
tout ça on fait en sorte que les coûts
pour les agriculteurs augmentent c'est
également vrai pour les transformateurs
ou
le besoin de main d'oeuvre est souvent
très important et ça poussait les prix
dans le fond les salaires à la hausse
et il faudrait peut-être également
mentionner le fait que les
transformateurs Canadiens se sont faits
beaucoup précises citron par les grands
distributeurs détaillants si bien que la
marge de manœuvre qu'ils ont elle est
très faible ce qui fait en sorte que
lorsqu'une hausse de mes coups j'ai pas
la marge d'absorption que je pourrais
que j'aurais dû avoir ou j'avais avant
si bien que je dois je dois passer il
m'en reste plus de marge doit passer
tout ça à mes
amis détaillants distributeurs donc tout
ça c'est le consommateur en bout de
ligne exactement au bout de la chaîne il
y a le consommateur qui appelle le prix
et et dans ce dans ce dans ce portrait
là avec toutes sortes d'acteurs qui
entrent en ligne de compte en quoi
l'arrivée de nouveau joueur comme le
suggère le Bureau de la concurrence
pourrait changer les choses au bénéfice
des consommateurs
je mentionnais il y a un instant qui a
eu il y a eu quand même des enquêtes et
puis même on a décidé de mettre un guide
de bonne pratique parce que on trouvait
que nos
distributeurs détaillants jouaient
peut-être un petit peu trop serré avec
les transformateurs notamment donc
d'avoir un nouveau joueur c'est sûr que
ça peut aider à ce niveau là toutefois
la question pour moi c'est comment on
attire un nouveau joueur parce que vous
savez ces joueurs là on les empêche pas
de venir au Canada ils ont choisi de ne
pas venir est-ce que c'est parce qu'ils
ne nous ont pas considéré parce que
notre marché déjà saturé qu'on a une
situation qui serait difficile pour eux
n'oublions pas qu'on est un très grand
pays avec une relativement faible dans
cette population alors il y a ces élèves
oui la concurrence ça pourrait aider
mais comment on l'assure cette
concurrence il est là le défi alors
est-ce que vous dites en quelque sorte
quelque chose d'irréaliste dans ce que
propose le bureau de la ou au contraire
il y a-t-il des moyens des incitatifs
possibles pour attirer ces joueurs
étrangers sans que ça leur coûte trop
cher
de vous dire si c'est irréaliste mais
c'est certainement pas facile si
nous étions un marché hyper intéressant
je crois qu'il serait déjà là et il faut
pas penser que les
distributeurs détaillères qui sont déjà
en place vont dans leur faciliter les
choses bien entendu et tout ça est vu
avec une certaine dose de méfiance par
les les joies indépendants c'est à dire
cette invitation à cette concurrence de
grande bannières étrangères je pense à
Carrefour ou à d'autres des Américains
qui pourraient débarquer parce qu'il y a
aussi cette possibilité de renforcer le
secteur des indépendants
oui tout à fait encore une fois dans le
marché dans lequel on évolue on a des
indépendants qui tirent bien
leur épingle du jeu mais souvent ils
vont arriver avec une offre qui est
différente et avec une spécialisation
qui est que ce soit au niveau de
produits différents ou encore de marché
de proximité et ainsi de suite mais ce
n'est pas nécessairement une solution à
l'inflation alimentaire parce que ça on
parle de produits davantage ni fait dans
plusieurs cas le bureau mentionne
également le problème qui existe dans en
région rurale et on peut penser qu'un
joueur international qui arriverait va
s'installer en milieu urbain et non pas
en milieu rural donc cet aspect là
d'augmenter la compétition à l'extérieur
des grands centres ça me pas très bien
couvertes par la lecture que j'ai faite
à tout le monde du rapport très bien
alors on voit bien
donc à la lumière de vos propos que
c'est loin d'être simple tout ça mais il
y a certainement une grande impatience
des consommateurs qui comme on l'a vu
dans les chiffres depuis longtemps
continuent à payer très cher pour leur
épicerie merci beaucoup encore une fois
Maurice Doyon à une prochaine